la haute couture parisienne elle
pourrait influencer la façon de rêver de
vivre la mode a besoin d'un nouveau chef
de
fil d'une figure de
prou monsieur
[Applaudissements]
di je continue de chercher collection
qui renîra des cendres de ces C
dernières années monsieur quelle est la
chose que vous désirez le plus c'est
dessiné les plus merveilleux vêtements
pour femmes que la terre est
connue Christian Dior a détruit la haute
couture et Coco Chanel est revenu pour
la
sauver pour ceux qui ont affronté les
horreurs de la
guerre la création les a aider à
survivre la légende de la talentueuse
Coco Chanel si seulement les gens
connaissai la
vérité
ch de la Révolution
[Musique]
vouszérireér peuttre pas les B mais
c'est le meilleur moyen de tourner
veravenir les choix que nous faisons
face à notre
monde ta maison va être
majestueuse c'est la mode pour
nous le vrai talent c'est de donner ta
vie pour quelque chose de plus
[Musique]
grand les gens ont besoin de renouer
avec l'émotion ils ont besoin de rêver
de se sentir de nouveau vivant nous
pouvons imaginer un nouveau monde pour
[Musique]
eux